how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and of
course like i always say if i hear any
new information about spider-man no way
home i'll be sure to do a video on it
and that's what we're doing today we
know that the second spider-man no way
home trailer is coming soon probably
this month or next month but today it
looks like we can narrow in a bit on the
exact day today we have two different
reports that actually coincide with one
another one of them is coming from an
insider and one of them is a possible
leak and of course if you love
spider-man and want to stay up to date
on no way home be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos so
first and foremost let's address a tweet
from daniel rpk because he is extremely
accurate when it comes to trailer
release dates in fact i don't really
think he's been wrong about a trailer
release date so far and yesterday he was
asked if he had any idea of when the
spider-man no way home second trailer is
coming and he said either the end of
this month or sometime next month now
this is kind of already what we assumed
we assumed a trailer is coming in
november really but we would be more
than happy to get one this month
obviously plus not to mention november
is only a month before the movie
actually comes out so that's pushing it
really close but now we have an actual
leak that could be for the spider-man no
way home trailer that tells us the exact
release date and how long the trailer is
going to be this was posted on twitter
by the account spider-man noe-home news
and leaks and we actually have
screenshots here these are supposed
screenshots of a computer system over at
regal theaters and what they are
basically saying is that they have some
information about an upcoming trailer
that is still locked and unnamed and if
you notice at the top left it says ncm
which stands for national cinemedia now
the person who sent this out says that
he or she believes that it is for
spider-man no way home and this is what
they said first thing i did once i got a
spare segment was go to the list of all
available trailers to see if i could
find the untitled one curiously it was
paired with all of the nuvia arcade and
welcome back stuff so i was worried it
was just a bumper ad or something but
once i clicked on it it showed me the
info page not a bunch to unpack but the
main thing is that it says class
provided which means it was provided to
regal and ncm by someone else meaning
it's not a new ad or a regal ad second
thing to notice is that the minimum age
is pg meaning that this has to be either
pg or pg-13 because g can be played
anywhere and r can only be played in r
and pg-13 morbius is unrated at the
moment so it is unlikely that it's
morbius no way home is also unrated at
the moment but it is very close to
release so it is most likely getting its
rating as soon as possible now if this
is truly the spider-man no way home
second trailer we know when it's going
to be coming out because it has a
release date for this trailer on the
screen and that is october 25th 2021
that is 12 days away from today and this
lines up with what daniel rpk said with
the trailer either coming at the end of
this month which the 25th is the end of
this month or next month so while there
is no guarantee that this is going to be
the spider-man noah home trailer it very
well could be which means that it could
be coming on the 25th also if it is
indeed the spider-man knowing home
trailer it also lists a running time of
three minutes and 33 seconds now the
teaser trailer was three minutes and
four seconds so this is just a little
bit more than that which is great
because they truly did give us a lot
with that teaser trailer and hopefully
with this second official trailer the
full one will get a lot of new footage a
lot of new plot details and hopefully
that shot of the three spider-man but
that's it for today just a quick update
on when we could possibly be getting
that spider-man no way home full
official trailer it could be coming
october 25th of this month leave all
your thoughts and comments down below
don't forget to like this video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
you